how are you doing today
hello steve i'm really good thank you uh
i want to
start with uh congrats on your work in
the movie um
as you thank you well you uh it's gonna
make a joke but no
um i've been asking this of a lot of the
actors i've been speaking with uh
recently and i would like to ask you
um when was you you've done so much
great work
um but what was the last time you
remember being really nervous
before filming a scene and can you share
why
i was quite nervous the first day of
shooting phantom thread
not because i didn't feel well prepared
i mean
i'd known about the film for seven eight
months
uh and i i'd got very close to
daniel day lewis and paul thomas
anderson i felt
safe it wasn't any fear of them or
it was just i kind of knew this film
was a big deal for me um
and so it was one of those kind of deep
breath
take a deep breath okay here we here we
go
and let's just channel everything
into getting this right so it wasn't it
wasn't so much that it was
nerves it was a it was more that i
understood that this film was going to
if it was if i was going to do it right
and the whole film was going to be
right it was going to make a difference
and it it has and it did
but generally speaking i don't get
nervous nervous i mean i might get
nervous the first performance of a play
but then after that i'm fine
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
today uh
how much fun did you have playing this
character because it seems like
it's just such a delicious role oh
that is the word i use mostly describing
it it's delicious
oh i mean what it is it was so great to
do it i mean i was very
very um i was very taken aback really
that i was asked to do it in the first
place
i mean i don't think you'd necessarily
think let's get a
you know a diminutive british actress to
play come and play this
rather foreboding scary woman from north
dakota
so i was very very delighted and chuffed
that the director wanted me
and it came my way to begin with
i mean playing bad people is there's
something
very very enjoyable about it i guess
it's because
i'm not a bad person so i'm i'm getting
something out i'm exercising something i
guess
but she was fantastic to play but
something i've really tapped on today
talking to other journalists i realize
there is something quite theatrical
about
blanche she has to be and that's not to
say that she can be big and
unbelievable she is big and what she
does is
quietly dreadful but there's something
quite theatrical about it
she she reminds me of terrible
shakespearean plays like titus
andronicus
um there's there's something very
uh blunt and brutal
about her there's if you don't do this
this will happen
if you don't let us keep this boy we'll
come and chop some of your limbs off or
yeah and she's not there's no messing
she's the kind of woman who says if
you're good you know you're gonna mess
with us you're done
we will deal with you and she does
it's quite theatrical yeah uh
i already have to rap and i'm just going
to say that uh i'm really looking
forward to seeing your work in the crown
i've seen season four already and it's
fantastic
and so good can't wait well that's good
i can't wait
either thank you have a fantastic day
and you too thank you